[Applause]
make that sound thumpier
canada is a magical place full of whimsy
and mystery
it's like middle earth but up north and
if wait uh
canada is a country uh about nine
million
a hundred thousand square miles
population about 30 million considerably
less than the united states but
culturally
uh similar but with many distinct
properties you guys don't care
about any of that so i'm not going to
talk about it i'm in canada
which means that it's time to review
canada's snacks because
since i arrived in canada i have now
become the best canadian reviewer
in the country
i would like to apologize for my
egregious statements of trying to claim
the best um
reviewer in the car but this is terrible
can we start over again
i'm in canada which means that it's time
for me to cleanse my palate of my
american sins
my mouth is full of sin dirty horrible
american sins
and i'm gonna cleanse that because i'm
in canada now which means that it's time
to get rid of all the bacteria that have
festered in my gut healthy bacteria
they're called probiotics
learn about them and i'm going to
replace them with the wholesome
comforting feeling of the bacteria of
canadia's candy
canada's candy canada
i have never had this much trouble
starting a video in my life
does it look like i have a bowl kind of
okay
so it's time to get down to brass tacks
i don't know what that expression means
but it's time to eat
which i'm going to do and i'm very
hungry what we have in front of us
me no us it's just me no one else is
here
what we have here today are what i
assume to be canadian snacks i actually
asked my members
what canadian snacks were and they
couldn't tell me
they actually started listing out
different snacks from different
countries
like sweden norway scotland earn
brew they mentioned and i i feel like
it's kind of an american thing where
well it's a canadian thing but it's kind
of like an american thing where they
assume that just because it's in their
country
means that they invented it which is
very american and
canada you can't take that from us we're
the opposite in [ __ ]
we are ignorant you are better than that
but i assume that these are kind of
canadian because
people said this this said made in
canada this has a maple on it which i
know they love their maple leaves
and bear paws we don't have bears in
america
if these are not canadian or if they're
not like in the essence of being
canadian
then i'm sorry i did my best i'm an
ignorant american
i already covered this i'll do the pass
so we're going to start
and and really we're going to start
actually somewhere that with something
that they
tried to bring to america i remember
this
kind of was a thing about like 10 years
ago or so they they try to make it so
it's like
they advertise it as like a lighter
chocolate
the idea being that there are bubbles
inside of it they're bubbles that create
more surface area for you to get more of
the
taste sensation of the chocolate and it
gives kind of a
texture to it i never tried it myself
but the idea was that
less actual chocolate means less actual
calories but you still get the full
flavor
because surface area is a thing
i don't know and also i don't know if
this is actually canadian but i've
noticed that there's a trend in terms of
textures that seem to be like fluffy i'm
not flipping you off
that seemed to be light light and fluffy
as opposed to like
more dense pure sugar things all i'm
doing is saying
words i'm not actually saying anything
of substance literally every word that
utters from my mouth
is just to give you the illusion that i
know what i'm talking about but i'm
really just filling out time
[Music]
chocolate i don't expect this to be that
different oh it's
crumbly because of the textures you can
see the tech
you can see the textures right you
you can see the textures is that focused
bubbles okay
that's just chocolate it's interesting
with the way the bubbles it gives it
more of a crumbly texture when you first
bite into it but once it starts melting
it's like all there i don't know about
the whole surface area thing
but texturally once it gets melted it's
just chocolate and it's good
again i don't know if it's canadian but
i'll tell you what is canadian
what i know for a fact is this ketchup
chips
so there was a lot of people that were
talking a lot about this and i like
ketchup i really do
i do not mind ketchup i put ketchup on a
lot of things fish sticks
taters fish
this is not a joke i'm trying to
remember what the hell i put ketchup on
not pickles i don't sometime i have in
the past
when i was a kid the sandwich of choice
that we would make
would be white bread bologna pickles and
ketchup
got ya you thought i was lying pickles
and ketchup
hell yeah brother hell yeah
okay that smells strongly of ketchup it
smells very strongly of ketchup
that doesn't look red enough to suggest
ketchup that looks purple
and i know there are purple potatoes out
there but honestly
it smells like ketchup i like ketchup
i feel like it would be better if i just
dipped
it's not better okay so in the element
of
replicating the flavor of ketchup on a
potato chip they've done a good job here
this does taste like ketchup the thing
is i don't like to dip my potato chips
and ketchup which is weird considering
french fries
in ketchup baked but baked potatoes no
ketchup i don't do baked potatoes in
ketchup i don't do hash browns in
ketchup some people do that i don't do
that potato chips are in that valley
it's weird because ketchup is
interesting i don't like straight up
tomatoes
i love ketchup i love tomato soup i love
roasted baby tomatoes baby tomatoes
child tomatoes youngling tomatoes what
do they call them
cherry tomatoes cherry dimensions i like
roasted cherry tomatoes i do not like
raw cherry tomatoes this is
okay
but it's not that good i get it but i
don't get it
right to each their own but not for me
maybe also going from chocolate to
ketchup
i feel like this is not a weird thing in
canada it's a weird thing to me but not
in canada
ah what's wrong with you guys why would
you do that
why would canada make this their
delicacy why do canadians
definitely actually factually dip their
chocolate and ketchup
that's weird of you guys that's very
strange that is not good
in the vein of more chips and to further
deviate from the world of taste by going
from chocolate to chip
these are crispers maybe canadian i have
no idea
but these are all dressed i thought this
is ass seasonings
these are some other kind of potato
chips except maybe not potato chip
wheat flour potato flour so not
necessarily potato chip probably more
like pringles in terms of actual chip
smells good all dressed up is like uh
vinegar
garlic onions probably ketchup
kind of like little uh little crackers
that's not bad i like that it doesn't
have a very strong flavor but it
definitely has like a
a pleasant flavor right the texture is
good i always love a good crunch
and that's a decent crunch this wouldn't
be like my go-to go-to snack but as far
as like just snack ability
i could see me munching on these and not
even realizing it i would tear through
this whole bag of seconds and nobody
would ever be able to catch me
you know i could devastate a countryside
of these ships
and no one would stop me i would go
through an
army of these ships blood spilling into
the fields
flowing like rivers down the hills and
all i hear is the screams of the damned
and in pain and death
and i go through the field and i just
stab over and over no one would stand in
my way
so it's freaking chip
i like that since i'm just going by
willy-nilly random here i'm going to go
for the whippets
also interesting thing about canadian
packaging is there's always
almost always french english
and french on both the sides which i
think is fascinating because obviously
canada a large portion of the population
speaks french that's all i have to say
about that just an anecdote i'm here for
the food not for the language
oh they're like little macaroons
that's a nice bit of chocolate i like
that it's really hitting me in the nose
with like chocolate it's really
powering up through there with chocolate
and i do appreciate it it's more of a
dark chocolate i'm not really like a
dark chocolate kind of guy but i also
recognize that the darker the chocolate
the more close you get to actual
chocolate
and when you get to the chocolate like
this like yes it's very sweet but it's
kind of very distant from what real
chocolate should be
and so you don't get a lot of the
benefits of actual chocolate when you
get there and with a darker chocolate
you always get a richer flavor to it
even if it's more bitter it doesn't
really matter you get the
closer to the god of chocolate
wow that was like an experience
not lying not exaggerating that was a
full experience that bite transformed
because it's like a very spongy
it's like a very spongy texture inside
because
it's a marshmallow it's a very soft
marshmallow i was thinking it was going
to be like
more like a macaroon a macron
where it was going to be more of a firm
marshmallow but i'm actually surprised
at just
how like look how squishy that is
it's sticking to my finger if it would
ever focus on this
that would be fantastic if it actually
focused on this watching
i'm just fingering this candy now
without it focusing on it but it's
sticky right
and so i wouldn't expect that kind of
like moisture out of a
packaged treat but it's very good
and when you first bite into it it's not
a lot of like flavor there
but the flavor really develops after a
while it's strange
that is very good it's kind of like a
s'more right
so the flavor really comes because you
got your top layer with like
the marshmallow and then the bottom
layer with a cracker and then
everything's covered in chocolate
so you have to let the chocolate melt in
your mouth but when it does it binds
everything together because
at first all you're getting is like
marshmallow which by itself not that
much flavor but as soon as the chocolate
starts to melt it really just flows
through everything
combines everything makes it all connect
in your mouth that is delicious
mmm i don't know if that's canadian but
if it is
good on you guys 10 out of 10. 10 out of
10. 10 out of 10.
oh my god those are amazing all right
tim tams
i don't know if it's canadian but tim
tam sure sounds canadian you got your
timmy horton which i'm going to do a
video about
i'm going to order everything off the
timmy orton menu you are not prepared
for what i'm about to bring to you tim
horton so expect that but tim tams it
sounds like you know
canadian hey whatever tim tam
sounds like it i don't know i noticed
like a lot of
god damn you canadians know how to live
it's like an oreo that's covered in
chocolate
and chocolate cream inside it's very
chocolatey it's very one note
but god the note is good right um
i was gonna do a bit where i like keep
adding ketchup to things but i'm not
gonna do that because this is just too
good to ruin i'm not gonna
i'm gonna do that very good i wouldn't
give this the same quality as the other
one because the other one really like
the experience was great this is just a
good cookie this is like a munchie
cookie you could just pound through
these
eight out of ten more in the same crunch
vein this is kind of combining the arrow
the arrow thing arrow arrow chocolate
the air
air bubbles um but in a crunch bar i
haven't seen this elsewhere so
if it's not canadian it's not american
it's a lot tougher than i thought it'd
be very very tough
[Applause]
dry too a lot dryer everything else so
far has been very moist
it looks like a wall insulation on the
inside but um
it's actually good i do like it it's
kind of like it's not honeycomb
but it reminds me of something that's
like
the same colors honeycomb i don't know
what it's called it's good
it's good right it's good i like it a
lot it's kind of like a butter butter
finger if the butter finger was a lot
staler and more
solid in the middle and more concrete
but the flavor is very good
ah
flick up looks like a tasty rock not my
ideal choice
but the flavor very good all right bear
claws i haven't seen these in america
and if i did i'm stupid
so shut up this is not what i was
expecting either
whoa they're big oh [ __ ]
i thought these are gonna be like little
bites like
like teddy grahams you know what i mean
but no these are actual like
big ass bear claws oh they're soft
too they're so soft they don't taste
good but that's cute
that's cute oh tastes bad but
cute very bad i don't like those
no flavor but cute i like the execution
get out of here [ __ ] it's made by the
same people the only reason i think it's
canadian is because there's a big ass
maple leaf on it so i'm probably right
i'm usually right about these things
these are uh maple cream
premium cream filled cookies
they're not very sweet but i don't think
they're meant to be i think the filling
has got to be like
maple syrup based because a lot of
things in canada are maple syrup based
pretty much everything i think they put
it in the water to be honest but not bad
okay so i'm not looking at this like a
cookie like an oreo or anything this is
just like kind of like a like a tea kind
of cookie
with coffee or something like that dip
in a few times you know you just snack
on you only eat two or three of these
ever you never eat a lot but it's still
not something i would go for
it's okay i'm trying to look at it
objectively but it's also
i'm never gonna go out of my way to get
these if i come back to canada and i see
these on a table somewhere i'm not gonna
go
i'm gonna be like oh i tried those i
don't really like them
now i need a pallet cleanser wow
all right smarties they talk a lot about
these in
in the u.s smarties are very different
smarties are in the small little rolls
and they're actually like a dextrose
powder candy they're old school
they've been around forever i imagine
these also been around forever but they
seem more like m
m's m m type things than other candies
[Music]
why did i get like a hit of cinnamon why
was it spicy
it was spicy i don't like that i don't
like that
i don't like that basic [ __ ] cara milk
it's caramel chocolate how bad could
this be
will this be spicy as well
caramel chocolate that's good but
about the same
bridge mix the original i don't know
what other version there is besides the
original
this is the original bridge mix i don't
know what's inside this it's like a
chocolate little egg
what are you
what are you there's a different one
there's a light brown and a dark brown
what are you what are you
oh it's bleedy that's what it was it's a
chocolate covered
gummy
okay and the other one was like i don't
know what the other one's covered in
bricky [ __ ] it's like some kind of
crumbly uh
crumbly something else interesting those
are peculiar not bad though i did like
them i just was not ready for a
chocolate covered gummy
now that i know that that's what it is
that's actually quite good okay so
now we've got these similar packaging
called oh henry's
they just look like a little like peanut
cluster chocolate caramel stuff
those are very good those are very good
crunchy peanuts chewy fudge creamy
carable covered in chocolate coating
i mean you can't go wrong with that
that's very good
it's a good snacking thing
that'll keep you going oh by the way for
those of you who are curious
i threw this down because it's popcorn
and it's not
canadian it's i bought this for myself
for
groceries and it was anyway
omg omg peanut butter clusters okay so
this is probably similar to oh henry
but this is omg and i imagine this is
just going to be an even more deluxe
version of that one
similar kind of cl cluster thing
so yeah
um
bad no i'm just kidding that's good it's
very good uh like i don't like the kind
of like genero
preserved forever peanut butter that's
in these type of things
it's kind of the same thing that's in
like those square rectangular packages
with the square crackers with peanut
butter
in the middle um that's kind of peanut
butter in here but even so
peanut butter pretzels chocolate like
you can't go wrong
it can't go wrong
goodies goodies okay in similar
to smarties these are goodies in that
these are nothing like smarties but much
like many things in canada
very cute names goodies smarties tim tam
cute these are made by twizzlers it even
says that up there so i don't know if
these are strictly canadian
but i don't remember these being in a
little u.s of a
kind of like a little jelly bean
kind of tastes like a jelly bean
these are jelly beans these are like
licorice jelly beans or candy coated
pieces of licorice which is what they
are
which given twizzlers i don't know why
they're doing this twizzlers doesn't
really make real licorice
they make twizzlers which i like but
everyone knows they're not really
licorice
yeah so you can see it's like the black
licorice on the inside maybe zoom
now zoom on me hey how you doing have
you liked and subscribed yet
maybe hey why don't you give it a
thought that's all
think about it you don't have to do it
it'd be cool if you did but whatever
no i'm not going to pressure you guys
i'm not that type of youtuber
you really have your own free will here
the like button is there for your use
only
indicative of content that you actually
enjoy and if you don't use it that's
fine that's up to you
but choose wisely why
oh oh my god okay so with that
so ends my adventure in terms of
snacking
with canadian snacks this was a good one
i found some snacks that i liked i found
some snacks that maybe
you aren't for me but still might be for
some canadians
and at the end of the day the only thing
i really didn't like was the ketchup
chips
ha got ya you have to like now because i
tricked you again you thought it was the
end
[ __ ] you always wrong ketchup seasoning
what the hell is this [ __ ] you want to
know why i got this popcorn
it was also a lie trick you [ __ ] you
gotta subscribe now
look at this this is a this is a popcorn
seasoning
ketchup popcorn seasoning you thought
that this was just for me grocery
shopping
i'm a better actor than you ever thought
[ __ ] i
tricked you so much like the video you
have to i'm exploiting you to do it you
have to like the video now
it's long whatever i don't care so i'm
gonna go microwave this
[Music]
okay hey welcome to the secret bonus
content if you're here it's because you
are smart enough to be able to unlock
this part of the video
congratulations thank you for solving
the puzzle um your prize package will be
delivered to you
via drone and so just yeah really i
didn't expect you to actually make it
this far but you always beat my
expectations you're smarter than you
ever look
and uh thanks for hitting the like
button as well because you're smart
enough to do that
and subscribing only the smart people
can do that so we got popcorn i don't
imagine this is gonna be very different
from
your standard popcorn what is gonna be
different is ketchup seasoning
i don't know why god allowed this to
happen but it happens
because why is this any different than
just putting ketchup on your popcorn
which you could do
at any moment i don't understand why you
actually need to have seasoning for it
but hey don't knock it till you try it
so i'm going to try it and then i'm
gonna knock
the hell out of it i'm gonna knock this
[ __ ] in the next century
[Music]
it smells like ketchup don't know what i
was expecting okay
i'm not [ __ ] footing either this looks
more like cheetos dust than ketchup
okay so i have coated this
it's not it's not like oh it's so
terrible i hate life
but what's wrong with just salt
i don't get anyone that has to dress up
their popcorn look
i like caramel popcorn that's fine but
at the end of the day
i just like basic [ __ ] popcorn with a
lot of salt
that's what i like but
that didn't taste that much like ketchup
either let's see what actual ketchup on
popcorn tastes like
kind of tastes just like ketchup the the
popcorn actually just goes away so hence
why probably they do the seasoning of it
because otherwise you're just gonna have
popcorn it's like if i put hot sauce on
popcorn
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
that's actually delicious then again i i
like i like frank's red hot a lot
sponsor me by the way or else i will
come after you i've made a new discovery
that was really very good hi it's me
again just wanted to remind you about
distractible which is
great and awesome and it's a podcast
that me and my friends made bob wade and
i
and uh we talk about a lot of really
important things that you should
probably know about about the world and
the stories that are
lurking within the world that we all
live in and also lurking in the shadows
of our mind and the madness kind of
spills out
so if that sounds like something you're
interested in click the link in the
description below and check it out for
yourself
i think you'll find to be very fun or
you can go to spotify or apple podcast
and search for distractible
and find it yourself but definitely go
now it's not going anywhere i'm just
trying to put a sense of urgency to this
so that you actually
feel like there's a need to do it now
and not later
but if you could do it now that'd be
great you have homework
try this hot sauce popcorn specifically
french red hot i don't know if it'll
work with all hot sauces but
try that get back to me in the comments
tell me what you thought of it
tell me if any of these things resonate
with you if any of them you don't like
let me know watch my other reviews
playlist in the description
suggest videos over there check them out
end card right here thank you so much
for watching
if you enjoyed this get ready for more
canadian reviews i've got tim hortons
next
and then i will be doing an extensive
review on all the maple syrups i can
find
thank you so much for watching and as
always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye